[Music]
randy's in
madison wisconsin got a time share story
what's up randy
hey dave my story is not unique probably
to
anything that you guys have already
discussed or anything but
i just kind of wanted to share and just
kind of warn people
about what you're talking about and it
kind of relates to what you say about
credit cards
you're just playing with snakes and if
you get
in that snake pit with them eventually
you're going to get bit so don't even
give them the opportunity to bite you
because that's what they're
really trying to do is lure into that
pit and
fill you full of their venom it's like
when we went and did it
i think they really truly try to prey on
poor people
the most because if you if you've got
money you
you're really not there trying to seek a
good deal on a vacation you just go on
vacation
you get the hotel room you book you get
the flights and you go but
they try to who i think prey on the
people that they're
we're trying to reel in by well we can
sell them this great
deal even though they might not be able
to afford it be the only way they can go
on vacation
what happened well in our scenario
it was we were just newly married
and we were we were thinking about you
know vacations you know heck we got 40
50 years hopefully together and
what do we want to do for vacations you
know we got this thing in the mail
you know say come join us you know
basically feed you for the you know give
you that free meal and uh
lure you into a casino night where you
could win gifts and
uh and then they they lure you into the
room by themselves and they give you the
sales pitch and uh they
they all you know just like everyone
else is that the pressure
the tactics that they use the promises
they give you
but even so more the stuff that they
don't tell you
we weren't told about numerous things
whether it be the
rca subscription that you had to use to
buy every year
whether it was the exchange fee that you
had to pay if you wanted to go outside
your week
you know and and we borrowed money you
know like you say you know the
borrower's slave to the lender
i walked out of that meeting that night
with them guys and you know they
they bring it in with the one guy and
then you know they they got the guy in
the back who can make you a better deal
you know what i mean oh yeah
and i i walked out of there that night
me and my wife sick to
our stomach as soon as we got in the car
and left that after we signed on the
dotted line we were sick to our stomach
what did we just do well little did we
know we had to write a rescission we
knew nothing about that because we
weren't educated in it they didn't let
us in on any of that you know that we
could have got out of it
you know when we got home the next day
but we were reeled in
and um with all the promises and uh
which company
well and dave i don't know who that was
um it was um
up at the wisconsin dells um outside of
madison and it was at christmas mountain
village
is the name of the resort but it might
have been like winter tree or winter
green or something like that i can't
really remember
bluegrass um well that okay that could
have been what it was but
um and i mean
and i know people there that own three
of these things and they don't ever
leave their yard
can you imagine that
i mean you're talking four or five
thousand dollars and you're not even
going on vacation but you own three of
them
boy i talked about a sucker one sucker
twice but
um so we were blessed dave unlike the
gentleman that you just had on before me
in wisconsin we contacted the better
business bureau
and the consumer protection agency and
they actually filed a class action
lawsuit on our behalf
and we we did not pay a dime to get out
of it and they won the lawsuit
and they agreed to let us out of the
deal and give us our money back
wow so praise god yeah you got it yeah
you got out with your skin
but other than that it's the same story
it's the same story
i mean don't even give them the
opportunity because just don't go in the
tiger cage don't pet the tiger
you think you're stronger than the tiger
but when you get in the cage you realize
you're not yeah don't pet the tiger
why pet the tiger just for just for a
pass to the zoo
it's silly that's what everybody